pour le canton de plaisir pas de
surprise les favoris seront bien au
deuxième tour la liste d'union de la
droite menée par le duo joséphine
commnce berger bertrand coca arrive en
tête avec 36 79 % des voix le parti
socialiste est second avec 23 points 53%
des votes le canton peut donc basculé à
droite une première depuis 2004 je pense
qu'avec plus de 16 % d'écart avec le
parti socialiste en termes de voix oui
on ne peut être qu'optimiste mais
au-delà de ça en optimiste parce qu'on
sait que le projet que nous avons fait
un bon projet pour le canton nous avons
le soutien des quatre maires du canton
nous faisons partie à chaque fois des
élus de la majorité nous allons siéger
avec la majorité départementale
tout ça fait que je pense que nous avons
le meilleur argument pour représenter au
mieux le canton toujours en course le
binôme socialiste nicolas eu frédéric
evrard espère combler son retard avec
les voix des autres partis de gauche
avec une gauche qui partaient un petit
peu en ordre dispersé dans un premier
temps sur ce premier tour on pouvait
s'attendre à évidemment ne pas forcément
finir devant madame clémence berger mais
ce qu cac
avec l'ensemble des forces de gauche sur
le canton nous avons de très bonnes
chances pour ce second tour que l'on va
entamer de manière
dynamique commencent à le faire pour
l'emporter le 29 mars prochain le front
national réalise lui une percée sur le
canton troisième lors des dernières
élections cantonales de 2011 avec 15
points 94 % le parti se place une
nouvelle fois sur la dernière marche du
podium le parti totalise cette fois-ci
20,35 % des votes on voit bien qu'il ya
une adhésion à nos idées et donc on fera
tout on va travailler à nouveau pour
pour se faire connaître encore et encore
et puis de plus en plus progressé en
local ce qu on se rend bien compte que
le local c'est très important pour pour
l'avenir à la quatrième place on
retrouve les verts avec le duo patricia
charton jarre lévis le parti a réalisé
un score de 9 56% nous avons même des
taux de 13% à bell par exemple dans le
canton de plaisir ces résultats pour
nous c'est très intéressant puisque nous
dépassons déjà la barre des 5% et
surtout nous mettons au
ballet des sondages est en fait donné
deux portes angle le binôme du front de
gauche gmail niati maryse mézières se
classe cinquième avec 5 84% des voix
enfin debout la france termine dernier
de ces élections cantonales à plaisir
avec 3 92% des gens fait le meilleur
score que le front de gauche est fait
sur le canton donc forcément on est
satisfait pour ce qui concerne plus
particulièrement plaisir on consolide
notre position de force d'opposition
donc on est on est très satisfait donc
vous c'est dès le soir compte tenu de
l'investissement financier et humain
qu'on a mis dedans par rapport aux
autres partis on n'est pas trop mal
après c'est vrai que si on compare pas
prendre parti on peut croire qu'on a
fait un mauvais score quand on ramène
cela ou à l'investissement qu'on a mis
dedans on n'est pas trop mal et surtout
qu'on a eu un bon accueil globalement on
a plutôt réussi notre campagne le duel
annoncé roi donc bien lieu pour ce
second tour l'union de la droite
représentée par joséphine commons berger
bertrand coquard tentera de s'emparer du
canton face au duo socialiste nicolas
hué frédéric evrard est ce que le
secteur basculera à droite réponse
dimanche soir